le monde de bob l'épongé pour toi gary
est remplie d'amis tout le monde avec
moi de douceur et de tendresse
j'ai joué avec une ima ya des sucreries
ici mais le 18 février attaque tout va
changer ne lui sont pas nettoyés kelly
brook peuple pour sauver leur monde
c'est quoi cet endroit bizarre ils
doivent venir dans le nôtre mais aucune
idée si j'ai rêvé de toi toute ma vie
c'est gênant comme situation y faire
face un super vilain ils vont devoir se
transformer en super héros magnifique
mais tu attaques
ça m'arrive quand j'ai le trac
[Musique]
bob l'eponge le film à perros hors de
l'eau lumière merci au mieux avec les
voix de cyprien matoukou squeeze menace
dans la mer au blé onze cas au cinéma le
18 février